hello everyone and welcome to round one
of the 2019 FIBA World Cup in hunt a man
Sisk in russia it's sean price versus
ding leerin and it's a well it's an
interesting matter because mr. press
here is a feeder master from Papua New
Guinea and he qualified for for the
feeder World Cup by finishing second in
the 2019 Oceania zonal tournament in
Guam where as well I think is just ding
he he gets gets to play wherever he
wants to play as he's the third highest
rated player in the world almost second
I think he's a point down behind Fabi
now and he's just winning pretty much
everything he won just a few a week ago
or two he won the sync fork up ahead of
Magnus cross and defeated him in the
tiebreaks if you've been following that
but as none of you really suggested any
games from round one I decided to show
this one as being is the top seed in the
tournament so let's see how this
gentleman affairs against their king
ding and also an interesting thing or
two about the Vita World Cup the total
prize fund is 1.6 million dollars with
110,000 dollars going to the winner
whereas if you lose in round one you
also get six thousand dollars so you
don't even have to win anything you
still get $6,000 it's not much you know
yeah you play in the World Cup to
qualify for the candidates tournament as
a two of the number one and number two
who finished highest in the Phaedo World
Cup go straight to the candidates
tournament so that being said let's
check out this very nice game mr. pres
has the white pieces and he opens with E
for with Knight to c3
sorry that's Knight to c6 I meant c5
Knight to c3 the closed Sicilian is on
the board and now d6 with g3 binding
preparing to fee and get to the light
square Bishop Knight to c6 and Bishop to
g2 and I hope I've fixed the sound
issues I know the sound was lagging the
board sound but probably has something
to do I switched from windows 7 to
Windows 10 and I still have a couple of
things to figure out as
the new version of Windows doesn't go
all that well with my recording software
but I'm gonna fix it in you know in time
with g6 fighting also preparing to
finger to the dark square Bishop d3 and
Bishop to g7 with Bishop to e3 rook to
b8 now Dean doesn't want his Bishop rook
to be on this diagonal and he also wants
to expand further on the Queen side we
have Queen to d2
maybe with ideas of Bishop to e6 once
the knight is developed a trade of the
dark square Bishop and the Dean
continues pushing on the Queen side with
b5 Knight GTE - and now before pushing
the knight back with night to d1 and now
h5 ding doesn't have a problem of
playing on both sides of the board and
if white cast skin side ding can already
start an attack with h4 so first white
prepares castling with h3 now h4 can be
met with the g4 and here their
disposition has been reached a few times
before a couple of moves were played
here but II 6 is a new move in the
position and it is already as a move 10
that we have a completely new game so
mr. pres castles we have a knight g37 by
ding-ding also prepares the castle and
now of course F for preparing g4 and f5
evidene castles King side white also
wants to start an attack against the
blacks King with a 5 by ding and now
rook the b1 you can't start developing
this night either way because the knight
is staggering the b2 pawn you don't want
to just give it up so first rugby 1 now
you're able to develop the knight ding
castles and now as dink decided to
Castle kingside white starts expanding
on the Kings side to attack the black
king with g4 h cap % g4 h captain g4 and
now not waiting for white to push f5
being pushes f5 himself and now this was
a good opportunity for white to go
Knight f2 from the knight from F -
nicely guards both of the points that
are under attack but mr. press decides
to go for a different line he captures
on f5 with each captures on f5 biding G
captures an f5 was also possible in
now just the g5 closing up the position
here and now if white can somehow get
for example the rook and the Queen here
it could get dangerous for ding but
that's easier said than done
we have Bishop to e6 by ding now going
after the a to pawn and now b3 blocking
the attack
we have Knight to d5 now attacking the
bishop on e3 also if the knight moves
from here then the knight can also
occupy the C 3 Square and we have Bishop
back to F do not allowing this straight
and now Knight the d4 and now the two
knights are well they are monster night
so you do have to get rid of them
Knight captures on d4 and now not
capturing you with the bishop but rather
seek after sandy for it's just better to
do it this way even though you double
your pawns here you well you basically
make White's dark square Bishop useless
and also you force a white to deal with
the backward C do point for the rest of
the game as due to the D and B pond
you're never getting anything like c4 or
C 3 in and if black even doesn't get
anything on the King said you can always
just double rooks and on the C file go
after the c2 pawn and something good has
to come out of it
we have rook to e1 attacking the bishop
on e6 Bishop to f7 and now Knight the b2
going for the c-4 square or maybe a 4
depending on what black plays and then
out night Stewie 3 a very interesting
move by ding as it seems like it he's
offering a pawn but is he really
offering upon now the best course of
action for white here is to go just
Knight to c4 as planned and then if you
ding let's say eliminates one of the
bishops knife capture screen captures
Bishop b5 check
you're gonna go King g3 and the game
continues from here but here mr. press
decided that it was in fact okay to
capture the night he played Bishop
captures night with pawn captures and
now okay you're not gonna capture with
the rook Bishop to d4 just win the
material but why not capture with the
Queen and this is exactly what the mr.
Prez did but Dean had a very specific
idea here and well feel free to pause
the video here and try to find this
specific idea being had in this position
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who
able to do it congratulations on finding
such a nice specific idea that Bing had
and for those of you who just won't
enjoy the show
rook to e8 and rook to e8 comes with a
with a very specific idea that well the
knight and v2 is almost undefended for
example if you capture the rook if the
rook from v1 moves then you could just
grab a piece here so it has to be very
careful not to leave the knight on b2
undefended so Queen f2 the Queen has to
keep an eye on the rook
so if black trades you can always
capture with the Queen ding captures
once rook captures Queen captures and
now Queen to b6 this was the point of
rook e8 this comes with check and now
the rook can come to a eight with an
attack on the Queen Queen King to h2 and
now rook to e8 we have Queen to f1 and
here ding faltered a bit here he can
just go for the straight probably what
he planned but Indian he probably
decided that it was better just to
prevent the knight from coming to see
for a zinc plated d5 he prevented the
knight from jumping to c4 he wanted to
completely dominate this Knight which
also works but it was also possible to
go Bishop captures rook captures and now
Queen to III just going for that 2 D 2
square and after Luke 2 b1 getting
drugged back into the game now you go
Queen d2 and now there are too many
threats here the Queen is well pinning
the Bishop Bishop the d5 is coming rook
2 e 2 is coming and it's this is just
game over but okay dink had a different
plan he played d5
block the knife from coming to c4 but
this also blocks his bishop from
entering the game so it's not as great
as the line we've just shown and it also
allows Knight to a4 which gets the night
away from being a target on b2 but the
knight on e4 is actually pretty much
useless leading place queen before now
completely dominating the night so King
the h1 not allowing the King to stay on
the second rank and also you don't want
this to go with Czech as you are
expecting something like Bishop f8 to d6
to go after this pawn and this is what
in place a bishop to f8 and the now
comes rook the c1 here for the lack of a
better move Sean finds c3 and rook see
somehow he wants to get the rook to help
out with the defense if you try
something like rook here the trade off a
pair of Brooks it doesn't help you for
example rook captures Queen characters
and Bishop d6 you don't have you don't
have a move here you're just gonna lose
this pond and this will be a threat the
bishop pair creates a wall here so you
can never even try to infiltrate with
the White Queen Albert okay after Bishop
f8 look the c1 as we already seen Bishop
to d6 now going after they spawn it's a
permanent weakness you cannot defend it
without the dark square bishop and the
night stranded there on a 4 c3 now the
night is now hoping to get back into the
game via night captures on c3 being
allows this with pawn captures Knight
captures but now Bishop captures on f4
now eliminating this well it wasn't
really the point that the pawn was
important but it was important because
it was preventing the bishop from
attacking the h2 square here we have
rook to c2 but there really isn't a
better move and now feel free for the
last time in this video to pause the
video and find the the best winning move
for Dean there are a lot of winning
moves but there is also a best winning
move well I'll give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you have
just found the absolute best winning
move and for those of you who just won't
enjoy the show Queen to h8 check this is
now a great check as the bishop also
covers the h2 square so you could try
either moving the King or Bishop to h3
and none of it is really good if Bishop
h3 then look III and you're gonna lose
this Bishop there's no way of defending
it you can't bring the rook here as the
best regards the h2 square and on the
other hand if King g1 then you get Queen
h2 check a very nice mating sequence
King f2 now Bishop g3 check King f3 and
now F for threatening Queen to h5 mate
so white has to prevent this let's say
Bishop to h3 now you go rook to e3 check
King to g4 and now Bishop to e6 is made
so this is what would most likely happen
if the game continued but Shaun press
figure out that there is no point in
continuing this and after
Queen to h8 he decided to resign the
game uh yeah that's one of the games I
chose this one like I said there's no
specific reason I chose it I just chose
it as ding is the top seed and I checked
out the game and I liked the game that's
why I decided show it abates Run 2 is
already being played and mr. press is
not looking all that waiting run - it
seems that mr. press will grab his
$6,000 for a loss in round 1 and you
know have to leave the defeated World
Cup but you never know you know the game
is still being played so it's hard to
say how but I feel free to suggest any
game from the Phaedo World Cup 2019 I
will of course look it up and maybe we
can check out some more games as I will
definitely be covering this event it's
an important event as it decides the -
well the two participants of the of the
candidates tournament sure that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Nikhil Dixit W Gallegos
Phillips Aafrin mark Lefkowitz and
Michael Panna for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here I think all
for watching and I will see soon
finishing the Capablanca saga with a
conclusion video after I fully regain my
sight checking up on your wonderful
suggestions regarding the Vita World Cup
and well just checking up on everything
that's going on so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day